some of the casualties of the recent
economic downturn have been students and
former students who are carrying huge
burdens of loans from their education
now these are not the government-backed
loans that have very low interest rates
these are loans taken out in the private
sector that have much higher interest
rates that students use to top-up the
money they need for their scholarship
now what happened was that students came
out of school at a time when jobs were
hard to find and incomes were depressed
or at least not moving up and so the
money that they thought they would have
to pay off their student loans wasn't
there and they were also in an
environment where it was hard for them
to renegotiate these loans because they
didn't look like very good credit risks
so a lot of people are stuck with loans
that they simply can't pay at the rates
that they promised to do what should we
do well if we were to forgive some of
these loans or have a government program
that will help to bail students out then
you could argue that anybody should take
out loans because they needn't worry
that if they weren't able to pay that
they would somehow be bankrupt that
somebody would always come to scoop them
up and help them to pay and that's a
problem that economists call moral
hazard that there's a probability that
people will take risks and behave badly
that increases when they know there's a
safety net waiting to catch them if
things go wrong now putting that aside
though I think it would be more useful
to consider some innovative solutions to
this problem the problem essentially was
that no one predicted that things could
be so bad for these students that they
wouldn't be able to pay their loans not
even the people who lent them the money
in the first place it's better for them
if the students actually pay so how do
you deal with this possibility a sort of
black swan that nobody thought something
like this could ever happen well one way
is to link how students raise money for
their education to the income that
they'll actually earn so instead of
lending a student money you actually
would buy shares in that student's
future income you become an equity
investor rather than a debt investor in
that student this is something that a
lot of people have wanted to do for
quite some time and there have been
startup companies that have tried to
figure out what the numbers would look
like to do this but there's a lot of
risk you don't want to constrain a
student too much in his or her education
but if a student enters college saying
I'm going to become a corporate lawyer
and then decides to become a poet well
the value of the shares might drop
somewhat because their expected income
might be a little bit lower so how do
you make a good match between students
who want to get some of their money
right now that they would earn in the
future to pay for their education and
investors who see a possibility of a
high return I think that to do that we
need to structure interesting contracts
we need to do the actuarial basis to
figure out how likely the students are
to actually make these earnings and then
we might have a shot at creating some of
these types of devices these types of
securities but I think the most
important thing is for this to be
something that is can be widespread if
there are any regulations that are
standing in the way of this we need to
perhaps reconsider them because what's
going to make investors most attracted
this to this kind of investment is if
they can diversify their risks by
bundling across students so just like
you buy bundles of mortgages which are
put together by government-sponsored
enterprises like Freddie Mac Fannie Mae
Sallie Mae even for students you would
be able to buy bundles of students who
have certain credit rating certain tiers
just like those mortgages did that got
us into a little bit of trouble a few
years ago but hopefully we can do this
in a way that's transparent that doesn't
exploit students and actually makes that
money available to them with a slightly
lower level of risk
you